gentlemen congratulations on this movie
i do like the idea here that when it
comes to friendship you can't plan it
you know it can be messy and you
certainly can't make a friend
be your friend or or know or like
anything about you specifically do you
can you recall
a long lasting friendship that you've
had or you have where at first you're
like i'm not quite sure about this
person i don't know if this is going to
work out
um jack i mean my most obvious one was
within my band we all got thrown
together and we didn't know each other
when we we got made into a band um and
me and louis uh did not get along one
percent i mean would use the word we
hated each other it was that strong and
now we are actually the best of friends
within the band which i think is
absolutely hilarious but just shows you
you know i think even even in those
those moments of angst it still breeds a
connection between you both
absolutely jack what about you
uh yeah i i have a friend he's still my
one of my bestest friends uh max
and in kindergarten together
we i met him in kindergarten and we used
to like kind of
he used to bug me because i i used to
want to play with him on like another
thing but he was just gonna play
basketball like oh my god you're
subscribed to basketball
nobody cares about basketball it's so
boring and i guess that was the brunt of
our not liking each other but now we
adore each other he's my best friend for
life
and we skate and we make music and we
have a blast that's awesome
if you had a bee bot like if you had to
be about following you around
knowing everything about you what maybe
like three things your bebop would
immediately pick up on
about you that it would then
you know
make itself out of and broadcast
i don't really understand i mean i think
i do but not really too much
what would it was it oh god what would
it pick out of our personalities about
us that people don't know yeah
um i think people would not know that i
am actually at home i'm quite a quiet
person
shakara yeah i'm quite
inside my own head i would say um
i work out a lot
and
um
i don't know i um i love food i suppose
jackman what is so unusual
what's your v-bot picking up about you
what is it what's it doing
uh
i i guess um
i don't know
maybe it's gonna tell everybody that
um
sometimes late at night i'll order i
guess the food thing i'll order like way
too much food
and eat all of it by myself like a bunch
of food from like chili's or some dirty
gravy i love that
yeah and also i was talking about this
my previous interview mushroom hunting
which is something that i've just
recently recently
begun to love
um and research and stuff i got like
this this field guide study book it's
like really cool and i just go out and
try to like match the mushrooms
it's dope
oh amazing
where does ron rank on like the cuteness
scale like if we're talking about things
like baby yoda he's cuter than baby yoda
okay
i think you got the box yeah that guy
is cuter than a gremlin i'll tell you
that true story yeah
i love that well gentlemen thank you so
much for your time congratulations on
the movie and um
you